it is minus 38 degrees in here I have
never been anywhere this cold I've had
to insulate my camera so the batteries
keep working and keeping microphone
close to my body so the wiring doesn't
freeze and fall apart this is the United
States national ice core laboratory in
Denver Colorado and I think it was best
to interview the scientists that work
here outside this giant freezer we have
about 20,000 meters worth of ice
represented here that's from probably
anywhere from 60 to 80 different bore
holes around the world the deepest one
we have is about 3,600 meters through
the ice sheet of Antarctica in our lab
the other sites that we had is about 420
thousand years old and that's from the
Vostok ice core drilled in East
Antarctica back into the mid 90s when a
new Corps comes in we piece it up and
ship it out to principal investigators
all of this is meteoric ice which means
ice that's fallen from the sky they
don't want any of the tundra or sea ice
because it would contaminate the
meteoric ice that we have one of the
principal investigators who was running
an analysis can check his system from
home and he asked if somebody was eating
potato chips in the break room because
he started seeing a higher amount of
sodium in his samples and they said well
yeah that's how sensitive this is if the
mains fail we have a natural gas-fueled
generator out in back it automatically
switches power to the freezer building
we're a hundred percent backed up on
everything each one of these tubes
contains a sample of ice from the Arctic
or Antarctic and the deeper underground
the call was taken from the older it is
all that born snow crushed down over
perhaps hundreds of thousands of years
along with anything else that happened
to be dragged along from the atmosphere
pretty much anything that's in the
atmosphere whether it's the atmospheric
gases or dust or anything like that
eventually lands on the ice sheets of
Antarctica and Greenland and will get
buried and trapped within the snow and
as that compresses in the ice it
preserves that information so we can
actually use these ice cores to recreate
what our atmospheric chemistry was like
dating back to about 850 thousand years
ago we can also determine what global
temperatures were and how they changed
over time by studying the stable
isotopes of oxygen within the water
molecules
essentially they're looking at the ratio
between Oh 16 and Oh 18 and by using a
lot of modern-day studies they can
figure out what the temperature was in
the area where that snow fell there's a
wide variety of ways that we can date
these ice cores with Greenland cores
oftentimes we can actually see visible
layers that change from summer to winter
based on the dust concentration so sort
of like tree rings count those seasons
going backwards and get a date that way
and then occasionally we will run across
things like volcanic ash layers and if
there's enough material within an ash
layers we can use radiometric dating to
get a very specific age on that volcanic
layer the margin of error in terms of
our our ages are usually within you know
plus or minus 10 years or so so it's
pretty accurate especially when we're
looking at ice that's a few hundred
thousand years old by understanding the
natural variations of climate change we
can better predict what's going to
happen moving forward now that humanity
has made a pretty significant impact on
what's going on with our planet in terms
of the amount of greenhouse gases that
we put into the atmosphere over the last
century we can better understand the
past and using that knowledge of the
past we can better model what's going to
happen moving forward into the future
thank you to all the team here at the
u.s. national ice core laboratory pull
down with description for more about
them and about their work and I think my
eyelids are sticking together yeah you
can't see it but you do have frost all
on your eyelashes really yeah